I can't have cell friends you just down
like okay and his teammates behind each
cell pressing right here on that corner
if you Nate on me you got those guys on
my body if you feel like I use right on
my body
here you're insane
guys this is the score esports best dub
series that was apex legends and yes it
is a battle royale but put your
pitchforks away because this ain't
fortnight apex legends was cut from the
same cloth as titanfall which means the
movement is frenetic the gunplay is
crisp and the addition of unique hero
characters brings an all new dimension
to the Battle Royale genre now without
further ado let's check out the best so
far from apex legends oh yes it says
he'll go in the smoke recovery there but
I think I might be asleep you I just
don't think that's gonna be one nice 45
knock number two does he find himself a
third I mean where's more numbers wait
I'm upset with numbers don't display all
the numbers 21 he's tied his all-time
all-time high of today thus far mass
he's posed with the mask if that's not
that's the champion dizzy oh my god
days days days I'm not you know crawl
back in this room met crawl back i
stealth right past them all hold on got
them all dead I got two of them there's
one more
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
apparently that's not help
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
employed
[Music]
I love the smell of napalm in the
morning
smells like victory
[Music]
[Music]
okay and they here oh there we go just
like we're talking about able to get one
though it does have the extended bag we
can flop off a little bit more shots out
that wing boy tries to get a little bit
of the flaky and on he goes the sliding
silent killer is able to get it goes
down with the logo able imitation one d3
skadoodle what are you doing
[Music]
oh good save little collateral baby here
for a second
oh my god dude
[Music]
guys love the red
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are the 8x champions
okay so there's no doubt those
highlights were sick
it's amazing how guys like shroud and
ninja can be so good at a game so fast
that just came out and then there's the
rest of us here are the best fails and
funny moments so far from apex legend
[Music]
okay okay wait what you what okay well
[Music]
did the hardest sight ever bro potato
[Music]
he's running like a ninja wrong no dude
I hide the sights of the singer butt
cheeks as soon as you shoot you lose
them
[Music]
[Music]
all right I'm just gonna run in we got a
little voice coming we're gonna all
squat I hope you boys black smoke and
some weed
[Music]
I got a mind [ __ ] get me right now
it's okay though
what an end up in the village what
dammit
go get moon dude I got I got squeezed
between the door and I died okay for
real yeah might be something going this
thing okay
[Music]
oh my god are you sick dude he just
means right next to you
that's all I've got Mike
a [ __ ] it freak out man [ __ ] hell
well guys that is it for the best of
Apex legends now look this game is brand
new so if you want to see more content
from it in the future from us well you
know what to do
Ark star the like button Mozambique the
subscribe button and zip line into the
comment section to show us some love
I'll see you next week thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]